One welcome everybody. This is Jason Rosen here once again with Dr. Kevin Connors
Well, we're going to go in depth on a product that we've recently released and I know
You know when I first you know brought some of the research to this product to Dr. Connors
I was pretty skeptical. I'm like I don't really want to carry you know a nutrient or a vitamin
Because so many people are doing such a good job of that out there
But then when I sent you to research on this source and some of the unique features of it
You know with the it's ability to penetrate the cell
That you are really excited about it and you know, then we
Decided to definitely move forward with this and another product you and I will talk about another time about
Vitamin D3 but this is a vitamin B12 pop product a methylated one called methylzyme
So Kevin tell tell us a little bit why
When I sent you that research why you thought this was going to be a really good fit and kind of stand by the you know keeping things unique and and simple
Well
hardly it's it's both of those I mean this is unique and then it has an enzyme tie to it so it's going to work better right
It's simple in that
Okay, if you're if you're if you believe in enzymes therapy that
If you could combine an enzyme to anything else you're trying to do it's going to work better
So if you're going to use a methyl product for the patient and then you have to give them an enzyme on top of it
If you can bite of it do a product just makes it easier and the patient's going to be more apt to take the product
Yeah, absolutely and then
You know some of the more unique features about this branded form of B12 and its ability to
You know penetrate the cell and you know some of the research that's
You've been done. It is a you know, it's pretty it's pretty interesting
You know a lot of people will get their you know blood levels up on
B12 but that doesn't you know it doesn't mean that that you know, it's getting inside the cell where it needs to go
I know that was kind of a big thing for you especially for the types of patients that you know you're usually working with which are you know pretty sick people
Well, that's the thing that everybody needs to remember that you don't look at a person's
Blood B12 levels because you'll look at their blood B12 levels and it'll be through the roof if they're taking 84 B12
So then they're in the patients the media thought is oh my gosh. I'm taking too much B12
Well, you got that high of a blood B12 because it's not getting into the cells
so
E12 is super important
I mean B12 is part of the methyde pathway in order for you to make
methyl groups
to
To be able to turn cells on and off
So in B12 recycles in the methyde pathway through
acetylcobolubid
hydroxycobolubid and methylcobolubid and it's depended upon a
couple of important genes so
If people have defects in those genes that the need for B12 is
even higher
But I'd caution you if you're not
Integynetics and you're not doing it egenetic testing then
Make sure you don't overdose methyl groups either. So that's why I like this product because it's
It's a thousand
Micrograms, so you're not gonna you just give them one a day
You're not gonna overdose them. It's in an enzyme base
It's gonna work better for the patient
It's just easy for a patient to take and stay on
Absolutely
Just another nice thing about
You know what we're trying to teach people and keeping things to that one capsule per dose serving is just you know
You know, we don't want people to over-methylate and go into that you know
Type of healing crisis. So it's just it's nice to be able to know you can just give them one and and keep an eye on things
Even if you're not doing genetics, and you don't have the you know the luxury of running all these lab tests
I guess it's just a really easy way to find find out as if you give someone this product at a couple a day
And they feel great for a few days
Well, you know, most likely they're gonna probably crash and then you need to stick them on that one capsule per day dose
I know something else. I think we chatted about was the
You know methylmalonic acid marker and homocysteine also being a lot better measures
of you know
The patient cells assimilating the B12. I don't know if you could touch on that a little bit
Well methylmalonic acid is a it's something that you would run if you ran an organics panel so an organic acid test would show that
methylmalonic acid and if that is
Showing really high that you know B12 is not getting it at the cells
So then you then you start looking okay, why
If you're giving a person a B12 product now
The general thought is if you go with a sublingual product, you'll have it a better absorption and you help to bypass the stomach and transic factor and
Any leak you got issues
The problem is that doesn't always work
and
Their absorption through the buckwheat buccosa isn't always that great as well
So they still are in a swallowing the product and if they have a transic factor issues leaky gut issues
They're gonna have poor absorption. Yeah, adding an enzyme helps the absorption piece
So that can be better and enzyme can also be a carrier of B12 because there's there's um
Other genes that you look for on in the B12 pathway whether the person can absorb B12 the TCN
One and two G is is the carrier G. That's the transport factor of B12
And people with defects of that can't get it into the cell as well
That's what the enzyme can help do and we see a you know, we do full genetic testing on everybody as you know Jason
Yep, and the
When you look at all the B12 factors in a person, it's it's got issues. So if they have any gut issues
They're not gonna be absorb it at very well. That's where the enzyme helps
There's a gene called the GIF gene which is the gastric and transic factor gene so that they're not even making as much gastric in
Transic factor as they should make and then there's the TCN one and two genes and those are the transport genes for B12
So added an enzyme to it helps it
You know helps promote cellular absorb should of the B12 not just to not just to test the absorption of B12
Yeah, absolutely. It's the more we learn about
These genes and how dependent they are on enzymes. It just
Just makes sense to combine some of these things with enzymes that are just you're just gonna help them
You know get to you know where they're designed to go
So yeah, just a exciting your product to make and
Yeah, definitely haven't seen a lot of B12 products out there with you know
Lens of enzymes and then having you know this
More unique form that definitely has a really good research on penetrating the cell and then
You know putting that kickstart on it with the with the enzymes
right
All right, well here it is the um, you know the vitamin B12. It's the methecobalamin form
so just for people that maybe are used to
You know buy in B12 off the shelf out Walgreens or Whole Foods or whatever
Maybe you could talk a little bit about you know the difference between
methylated form of B12 and you know, like another methylated form
Yeah, others there's really four different B12s of the bark
It only three of those you should use
So what is acetylcobalamin and that is that's a good form of B12
um, and that
We use that a lot in our office what is hydroxycobalamin and we use that a lot in our office
And what is methylcobalamin and we use that on our office
So knowing which one to get the patient you have to know more about genetics
So you can't really go wrong with any of those three B12s
Um as far as as far as injury in the patient unless you go wrong on the dosage
So many times people will do a mthfr test because they want to get deep in
in a
Noid what's going on with the patient or the patient will come in and go I have an mthfr defect
So I need more methyl groups
And that is only partially true
Because you gotta look at a bigger picture of the gene
So if they have defects in there a biopterate pathway
mthfr if you add methyl groups to someone with mthfr defects too many methyl groups you'll push the biopterate pathway
And if they have defects in there you're going to be
Bessied with their serotonin and dopamine balances
And you could have some mood issues so you could crash a person mood-wise really quick if you give too many methyl groups
That's why it's beneficial to have a time to an enzyme
Um, but that's where I started out this conversation is
Always start with low dosage so only do one a day to begin with
Um and go at least a month before you change that dosage that would be my recommendation
The fourth type of B12 that I think you should stay away from is the say it'll come all of these
Yeah, that's typically what a person's gonna buy a wildard or something like that
Or it's been fortified in their you know microwave dinner or something
Yeah, and you'll see it a lot and even some
What you would think would be a better bread and it's in their multiple
So yeah, I mean, that's one of the hints, you know, I always tell patients, you know
All the way I have to become a nutritionist to learn how to take a good vitamin. Well, there's some hints. How how is the
Is the mineral key-lated in the product there's a big hint whether they care about it or not right
What form of B12 and what formal folate
So if it has in that in that vitamin if it says folate as folic acid
Um, then you that's folic acid is synthetic
So then you know they don't give a rip about
Wonder bread for gonna sake. Yeah, sorry. I don't want to get sued by them
It's like it's like poison. I mean that should be illegal to use folic acid
Um, so you always look at that that's my biggest key if you go if it says
folic acid as
natural folate or as methyl tetrahedral folate or something like that then you know they care. Yep
But if it says folic acid it nothing else or folate as folic acid. Yeah, I tell people throw it away
It's not fit for bad or beast. Yeah, and like you said, it's amazing to see even you know
You'll see it in even high-end product. I mean, it's changing thankfully, but I mean it is still pretty common to find it in the
Quoting quote it is a clinical base
So I just kind of makes you bad and you see it a lot with the with people that are
You know, multi-level companies that maybe you know were formed off of a good product at one point in time
But then they decided to branch out at vitamins and all this so that they yeah, just
Well, why do we need you know a methylated B12? We can get this one for like a tenth of the price. Let's just dump that in there
Oh, yeah, that's what the CEO of the company is like we could save about 30 cents a bottle by doing this
So anyway
Topic for another day. So I think that probably you have a pretty good idea of rounds out the product. It's
simple yet powerful
I would just say
We really think this is going to be a huge blessing to your patients
And just yeah if you can take anything away from this just start them at one a day if you're not doing oats testing
or anything else like that
um to learn more about the product you got the website up here you can e always email me and then
We both post all these videos on each other's youtube channels
So here's dr. Connors and then here's rs reus enzymes
um
Dr. C anything else to add a close-up out here?
Uh, just to encourage people to keep using good nutrition and keep learning. That's the biggest thing
Amen all right, I was a pleasure to have you and uh looking forward to the next time we get together
All right, goodnight everyone